on april the 10th 1938 austria famously
voted via referendum to join the third
reich and become a part of germany
this came after german troops had
entered the country in march in order to
stop the fascist chancellor and dictator
of austria kurt shushnig from
holding a referendum on whether or not
austria should join germany
the official reason the germans did this
was because they believed that the
austrian government was going to cheat
and make sure that austria stayed
independent
in fact shushnik was so desperate not to
be annexed that he even legalized
opposition parties on the condition that
they campaign against
unification anyway german troops entered
austria and the german reichstag passed
legislation that annexed the territory
on the condition as an austrian
referendum approved the vote for the
annexation called the angelus was
approved by 99
of the country in a 99 turnout sounds
legit
also the ballot looked like this with a
much larger and central yard circle
making it clear who you should vote for
also the ballot wasn't secret and our
members of the varfan ss were at polling
stations
so the question surrounding all of this
is how popular was the idea of the
angelus in austria whilst the conduct of
the referendum makes it seem like it was
forced upon the austrians against their
will
the truth is not so simple the notion of
austria and germany being unified was
not a new one and can be traced back to
the unification of germany after the
first world war and the disillusion of
the austro-hungarian empire
austro-german unification became a
popular force but any such notion was
forbidden in the treaty of versailles
in fact unification with germany was
considerably more popular in austria
than it was with germany during the
early interwar years and was
particularly strong amongst veterans of
the great war you see many austrians
felt that the peace of versailles was
hypocritical since it gave all of the
peoples of the former austro-hungarian
empire the right to self-determination
but none was given to the austrians
so using the 1927 election as a
demonstration we can see just how
popular the idea evangelist was with the
austrians
during this election explicitly
pro-unification parties achieved over 65
percent of the popular vote
the real change came in the 1930s when
in germany some chat with a funny
mustache took power and austria itself
had a fascist coup
the rise of hitler turned the left-wing
austrian parties away from angelus
because whilst they wanted to be a part
of germany they didn't want to be part
of
that germany the fascist government
quickly went to mussolini who promised
to defend austrian independence
that was until hitler offered mussolini
an alliance after which mussolini
promptly stopped caring and did nothing
when the germans took the country
this just demonstrates the difficulties
discussing the angelus whilst oshery was
declared to be the first victim of nazi
aggression it's important to note that
many in fact a sizable majority of
austrian supported unification with
germany
it's thus likely to conclude that had
the nazis run an honest referendum
they'd have still won
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching and a special
thanks to all of these patrons you see
on screen for their generosity in
supporting the show
and a particularly special thanks to
james bisonette party boycott
osaka flash rob waterhouse chris wicker
michael reynolds
thomas mcgill gustav swann winston k
wood skye chappelle
the amusement archives adam harvey and
lastly rafale